the White House says voters should not
trust a new report on the Senate
Republicans health care bill the
Congressional Budget Office estimates 22
million more people will be uninsured by
2026 if the Senate bill replaces
Obamacare that number apparently
convinced another senator to vote no
Susan Collins is a sick Republican to
come out against the plan Senate leaders
can only afford to lose two GOP votes
Nancy Cordes is on Capitol Hill Nancy
good morning good morning and because of
that growing GOP opposition the bill may
now not come up for a vote this week as
planned several of those Republicans are
saying that they will block attempts by
GOP leaders to bring the bill to the
floor as early as today they view those
CBO numbers as proof that this
legislation needs a lot more work I
think if you're on the fence about the
bill the CBO score did not help South
Carolina's Lindsey Graham was sounding
pessimistic last night and he's likely
to vote yes his colleague Susan Collins
announced she's a no tweeting 22 million
people lose insurance Medicaid cuts hurt
most vulnerable Americans one in five
residents in her state is on Medicaid
according to the CBO report the GOP
bills steep Medicaid cuts would force
enrollment down by fifteen million
Americans over ten years
reducing the federal deficit by 321
billion dollars
many Republicans say that's a good thing
these programs are growing at an
unsustainable rate as for Americans in
the individual market average premiums
would be about 20 percent lower than
under Obamacare but some Americans would
receive smaller tax credits meaning many
would end up with higher out-of-pocket
spending on health care hit hardest
would be older middle income Americans a
64 year old making roughly $60,000 a
year would go from paying about $4,000 a
year to sixteen thousand by 2026 no
matter how the bill changes around the
edges it is fundamentally rotten at the
center the CBO estimates that under the
GOP plan 15 million people would drop
off coverage next year primarily because
Obama
penalty for not having insurance would
be eliminated
GOP supporters argue the government
shouldn't force people to buy insurance
anyway that's not denying somebody
covered just a choice by them to drop
coverage they already have because they
don't have to pay a fine pulling this
belt bill even temporarily would be a
setback for the White House which is
slamming the CBO saying that the
nonpartisan office has a history of
inaccuracy the president has been
working the phones calling undecided
Republicans and the Vice President is
sitting down for dinner with four of
them tonight Norah breaking bread all
right Nancy thank you so much